[Music]
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
ryan nicodemus is on vacation today but
don't worry we got alabama here we got
tk coleman in the studio and coming up
today on this free public minimal
episode we're joined by one of our
favorite musicians matt nathanson whose
stunning new album boston accent is out
right now we're gonna chat with him and
a listener about expectations we also
have an outstanding lightning round
listener tip an added value segment for
you you can check out the full
three hour conversation that we had on
the maximal edition of episode 352 where
we answer four times the questions and
we dive deep into matt nathanson's new
album that private podcast episode is
out right now at theminimalists.com
private or just click the link down in
the description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck alabama who's our
first question today our first question
today is from amanda in cairo egypt
how do i go about lowering or
eliminating expectations either in
relationships or situations
so we're here with matt nathanson right
now he has a brand new album out it's
called boston accent and i'm sure along
with this album comes all sorts of
expectations oh yeah will i go double
platinum again
will the streamers put me on playlists
will the venues fill up when i go on
tour this fall which by the way if you
want to see the minimalists you can just
come to one of matt nathan's shows when
he's in la will be their front row
singing along
but uh matt there's all kinds of
expectations here you've been doing this
for a while in fact
you're coming up on the 30-year
anniversary of your first album oh yeah
which
and yet you became a overnight success
15 years into your career
yeah
and there were a lot of expectations
that sort of were heaped on to you at
that point i'm sure that untangling
yourself from that web has been a
another 15-year process yeah i think
expectations are the uh
are the enemy of all the good
i just think
you don't need them at all i think um
in fact every time they show up
you kind of have to ditch them i feel
like it's just a fact it's sort of like
sort of like termites like you wouldn't
have termites hanging around
and be like oh that's cool you guys just
munch on that you know that beam
it's like you just don't want them you
get you got as soon as you see one
you call somebody to come help you get
rid of them yeah and like that's it's
just expectations are for suckers man
that's just not the way to live i'm i'm
way out on them and i think and i have
them all the time so i have to
constantly every time they show up it's
got to be like a check engine light and
i have to be like okay what's what am i
afraid of that this is coming up what am
i not seeing for what it is
it really is and it was the same with
all most of anxiety is based on things
that don't exist right and it's like um
an expectation is totally
just as soon as it shows up you have to
sort of go through the steps to sort of
unwind it and be like thanks for coming
and then kind of pat it on the ass and
send it on its way
every expectation is a roadblock on the
highway to happiness
and the weird thing is about those
roadblocks is they're self-imposed we
drag them onto the road and then we run
into them yeah yeah
yeah
so i'll say two things here first
the idea of lowering expectations or
limiting expectations it's a defense
mechanism it's born out of a desire to
or perceive need to protect oneself
right because the logic behind it is hey
if my expectations are too high i might
get hurt or disappointed or angry at
someone if my expectations are not
limited they don't have these
constraints you know um i might be
brokenhearted and so what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna search for a method that
allows me to limit them or lower them so
i can't be heard anymore the first thing
i want to say is that doesn't even work
because you can be just as easily
broken-hearted by low and limited
expectations so for instance if you have
a low expectation that someone is
willing to pay you a certain amount and
you charge low and then you find out
they would have paid you higher you're
going to be angry at yourself like darn
it i should have had higher expectations
right
or you have a low expectation of how
much someone is willing to help you or
be there for you so you don't ask for
what you need you don't state what's on
your heart and you don't get what you
need and later on that person says oh i
would have been happy to help you and
now you're angry at yourself so there's
nothing about a lower limited
expectation that protects you any more
than a high expectation expectation
itself is capable of breaking your heart
in both directions the way out
is to make the shift from the prediction
paradigm to the paradigm of play the
reason that we have these expectations
is because we go beyond what we actually
know we think about the future and we
try to predict what's going to happen i
do this all the time with the mba like
tk how are the chicago bulls how are
they going to do this year i have no
clue because it's the future right but
what i do is i make a prediction oh
we're going to be the the number three
seed in the east and and we'll get to
the second round and then i become
attached to my prediction because now it
says something about my foresight my
intelligence i get attached to the
happiness i think i will feel if they do
as good as i predict it and now that
prediction becomes an expectation and i
go from not knowing the future to being
angry at every referee and every
opponent that keeps the bulls from
fulfilling my prediction right what i
could have just said instead of trying
to predict it i could have approached it
playfully oh i don't know how they're
going to do
but man i love to watch and see how it
unfolds i'm curious to see how lonzo
ball is going to do this year i'm
curious to see how demar derozan is
going to do this year and what's
beautiful about the play paradigm is
that when you play you're only focusing
on your contribution watching the bulls
that's something that i can control
right keeping track of the score i can
control that and i feel good but
prediction externalizes me it puts me in
the control of referees and other people
so don't force yourself to predict the
future so that you become attached to
them in these expectations that break
your heart or form
play around with what you can control
and let the expectations go
it ties into what we talked about
earlier about why are people so afraid
of their awesomeness
you asked that question yeah yeah and
it's like you'd rather invest in
something like expectations of a
situation that you can't control
you'd rather invest in anxiety about
something that may occur
that's rather than the vulnerability
of investing
in
[Music]
the chaos and beauty of the self that's
so good because like we are
we are of fallible
mess
humans
so we'd rather project onto something
that we think we can that we can either
blame or have control over that kind of
stuff instead of investing in this idea
of like i'm awesome and all of my sort
of messiness and all of my
glorious
self that's good and that was the idea
is like i think it's so vulnerable and
so on
it's it's a it's messy to love yourself
yeah and it's really easy and clean to
have expectations about things that you
that you know and it's ener it's all the
same energy so i don't know why it and
energy is finite so why instead of
focusing on this if you focus that
energy on loving yourself and you turn
that power into something that fed you
instead of drained you you i mean think
about how amazing we'd all be if we
could actually do that you know get up
in the morning and be like yeah i'm
beautiful like i've got this little bit
of a belly here that's isn't that cool
that means i've i remember that food
that was great it's like this beautiful
sense of like isn't this rad my shape is
changing as i get old instead of
expecting like why am i looking like
this i'm supposed to look like this i
want to look like this i want to be this
instead of like this is me i'm going
yeah you know people feel like they they
need that self-condemnation to be
motivated
to change right because if if i can say
i'm beautiful the way i am then won't
that mean i'll lack the motivation to go
to the gym and we we don't have a
concept of how we can evolve or change
from a place of self-love because just
as i can say my body is beautiful right
now my concept of a different body that
i want to play around with that too is
beautiful and the exercise that i want
to do that too is beautiful it can all
come from this place of beauty because
when you love yourself how much more fun
is like i don't know if this is gonna
get edited but like if you angrily
masturbate that's like not fun right
right like who wants to do that like
just like i'm gonna masturbate
you know what i mean like
you know i mean it's like it's got to be
this sort of like surrender to the self
and it's the same idea it's like you're
not going to want to go to the gym and
throw around your body if you don't
think your body's beautiful and rad do
you know what i mean like you're not
going to want to get in bed with your
lover or your significant other and like
play around with them if you're if
you're if you think you're not beautiful
and it's not and we've got this stigma
in the world of like that well if you
think you're beautiful you're arrogant
and it's like well that's not you have
to be more you know tamp that down and
it's like no this is the opposite of
something that needs to be tamped down
this thing needs to be pumped up because
we're spending so much time having
expectations about things that we don't
even it's like yeah you know conjecture
about like well it's like trying to
wonder what the weather's going to do
like instead of just being like it's
raining how oh rain on my skin yeah yeah
yeah i mean like
great one more very quick word about
expectations
an expectation without an agreement is
just an assumption in disguise
if i expect you to meet me at the coffee
shop at 2 p.m and you didn't agree to
that i don't have an expectation i have
an assumption and i'm calling it
something else
if you agree to meet me at the coffee
shop at 2pm i just have an agreement
with you and i'm going to hold up my
part of the agreement hope that you do
the same and if you don't then i have to
make the necessary adjustments to ensure
that i'm able to create the sorts of
experiences that i want so what i would
say is get rid of expectations
altogether call them what they really
are assumptions and don't have
assumptions and instead translate your
desires into agreements so that you
don't have to have assumptions and you
don't have to worry about this
expectation business what tk just gave
us there was a recipe for decluttering
your expectations right that's beautiful
amanda i'm gonna send you a copy of our
book it's called everything that remains
second book that ryan and i
wrote together and it's really about
letting go of expectations to live more
meaningfully ryan and i not only walked
away from these corporate careers and
the way the world expected us to be to
be these suit and tie successful guys
walked away from those expectations and
sort of created our own new agreements
with each other and and ultimately with
with ourselves
let's move on to some actually you know
what let's move on to our lightning
round so we answer your questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response and we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now you
can find all of our minimal maximums in
one place
minimalmaxims.com now matt this is kind
of like what you do with your lyrics
they're all minimal maxims in a way and
earlier on the private episode here we
were going through each song and sort of
talking about some of these these lines
there's an entire world in these lines
so what we try to do is we answer a
question with something pithy and we can
ramble on a little bit if if necessary
alabama jacob has a question for us what
is the most meaningful thing you guys
have done
i hate this question
wow
and let me explain why that's a tough
one and so here's my pithy answer for
you competition confounds contentment
yeah
so like what's the most like here are
the 10 most meaningful things i've done
i need to do something even more
meaningful in order for my life to be
meaningful and i know this isn't the
essence of jacob's question if i'd be
charitable to jacob here jacob's saying
hey i'm trying i'm trying to find
something meaningful to do with my life
and i totally get that but the problem i
run into is i did something meaningful
last year i guess i have to top that now
because we're so in love with
superlatives i
need something to be meaningful not only
do i need to be the most i need to be
meaningful i need to be the most
meaningful this meal isn't delicious
it's the most delicious meal i've ever
had matt nathanson's new album boston
accent isn't a great album it's his best
album and when you start saying these
superlatives that is another type of
expectation right and we expect to
constantly do better and better and
better well better relative to what it's
all about our own preferences or
whatever i might think boston accent is
your best album or i might think show me
your fangs is whatever it is that's just
my own opinion my own preference right
we try to map that onto the world as
well we hear this conversation all the
time who's the greatest of all time
who's the goat basketball player it's
like well according to whom right
according to what stats or metrics or or
whatever and so
i'll tell you one of the most meaningful
things that ever happened was yesterday
i was walking in the woods by myself and
i just had a profound moment of calm and
peace
and i didn't share it with anyone on
instagram
i didn't have my wife there i didn't
have my daughter there i was all by
myself and that was meaningful but there
are other times where i've spent an hour
with my daughter reading poetry that she
didn't understand
and that was meaningful i don't know
what was the most meaningful but it's
always meaningful to me if i'm there if
i'm actually there in the moment i'm not
staring in the rear view i'm not looking
far ahead of what's going to happen next
week or my to-do list
but it's wherever i am
right here right now
1000 i back all that
i had a great i had great tea this
morning at breakfast
it was like i just sat there and
journaled
and uh drank this tea and i was like
this damn good tea
it's warm and it's like we've got that
nice milky balance
and i was writing in my journal i liked
the way the pen felt in my hand i liked
the way the paper felt under my pen
i felt i felt exactly
that felt like
one of the best things i've ever done
what you're talking about is noticing
yeah in that moment it's like they're
all the best things you've ever done
because it's like yeah if you're there
in it like you're saying if you can
notice it
it's all great usually when we notice
it's because we're in some sort of pain
or suffering or discomfort and we notice
those things like you notice your shoes
if they're too small
but
the ideal shoe you don't notice it at
all right and so what do we have to do
we actually have to pay attention in
order to notice unless there's some sort
of
direct pain going on in our lives
something that's creating discomfort of
course we're going to notice that but as
soon as your knee doesn't hurt you don't
notice that your knee doesn't hurt right
now tk but as soon as it starts hurting
then you notice it well the key to
living meaningfully
is to notice it when it doesn't hurt
yeah you know i heard a monk say
that
the reason you leave the world behind in
order to find god
is so that you can learn how to find god
in all aspects of the world
meaning that there's so much to notice
in life but our ability to notice is
compromised by all of the noise
and the noise has conditioned our very
habits of listening and so you leave the
world behind and you find a quiet space
not because god is only found in the
quiet spaces but because your capacity
to notice to name to recognize to
receive to listen to hear is cultivated
in that space of solitude in that space
of silence and then you go back to the
world and the spiritual journey is
complete because now you can do the
ordinary things that you once had to
abandon with a sense of the sacred being
a part of it all
i'm gonna give my most meaningful
experience
it's not my most meaningful but you know
what i mean and i'm gonna change it on
the fly because i have something else i
shared with you before uh and it is
i stopped living up to my potential and
i started living from my sense of
possibility
i came to the recognition at a point in
my life that living up to my potential
was a trap a set of golden handcuffs
because i would try things and people
who respected me people who liked me
people who knew me since i grew up
people who thought i was something
something amazing they would say man
you're so much more than that
like you've got so much more potential
than that person that you're dating than
that place you're living than that
lifestyle that you have then that thing
that you're doing i mean imagine if i
looked at you josh and i was like man
the minimalist like bro you got you got
potential to make millions like
advertisements suck bro listen let me
show you the numbers how much money you
could make if you just started charging
for advertisements guys just telling my
agent
[Laughter]
once a month he calls me he's like you
uh still think advertisements ah that's
awesome and and so we have these ideas
for people like ooh when i look at you i
can see who you can be right and and i
tend to think my ideas of you are more
than your ideas of you right and so that
could be a set of golden handcuffs
because you spend your whole life trying
to live up to someone's ideals for you
and those ideals aren't even your ideals
it's like you said in the documentary
man i was living the american dream but
it wasn't my dream
and we live in a world that tells us
over and over again follow your dream
and we emphasize the dream without
emphasizing the yore
it's totally accurate there was this
great idea of um
you know you're living in someone else's
fiction when things don't make sense for
you do you know what i mean like
and and that's the idea we're living in
a world where people are trying to chase
after someone else's ideas of a dream
you know you're in someone else's dream
and that's we spend most of our time in
other people's dreams
like and it doesn't make sense we don't
know why we hate ourselves we don't know
why we keep falling short of our
expectations for we don't understand why
nothing works yeah and it's because we
have these dreams that we're living in
that have been put in place by someone
other than us yeah and i'm not you know
what i mean like and we're trying to
meet the expectations of that experience
and that's just like a recipe for
disappointment and it's why so many
people to tie it back it's why we have
such such a disappointment in this in as
humans why we get to the end of our
lives most of us and instead of being
like yeah
yeah look what we did let's die now
we're like no no i don't want to die yet
i i got there's more you know i i didn't
meet the thing i have to or i gotta i'm
getting older i gotta change this part
of my face i don't like the way this
looks like no no you look old you look
older like how badass is that your skin
is sagging because you've lived your
life like how that's that rules like
your body's changing based on the life
that you've lived like
that is glorious and instead we fight
tooth and nail against all that stuff
because we're not that's not our dream
we're living somebody else's dream
somebody else's concept that's a
profound point about how you know it's
not working when you don't make sense to
yourself
because that's an indicator that you're
prioritizing making sense to everyone
else because when you don't make sense
to yourself
everybody else can look at you and be
like oh yeah you have this label you
have this job you show up on time you do
all these predictable things you're fine
you're great and the price we have to be
willing to pay to make sense to
ourselves is to say hey i'm gonna leave
behind
right without saying a word in order to
start my new life and so for me man i
decided that i'm gonna embrace being a
loser in other people's eyes in order to
be the hero on my own story i'm gonna
embrace being an enigma to other
people's minds in order to live the
excited enthusiastic life that i want to
live so i stop living up to my potential
and all the people out there who are
disappointed in me man i love it i
embrace it keep that energy but i'm
loving my life whatever town you think i
should be living in whatever career you
think would be living up to what god has
placed in me i don't want it yeah i want
to make sense to myself not to you dude
because and i say this i'd say they
don't even see they like books i don't
like and they like movies i don't like
and why am i basing anything on what
they like you know what i mean like they
they think so and so is it they you can
see it on a very superficial level and
you can sit on a really deep level their
idea of love is not my idea of love
their idea of friendship is not my idea
why am i basing any of my own self-worth
on people who have completely different
ideas about almost everything in the
world do you know what i mean like why i
have to be the center of this i have to
be the pole that i come to am i'm true
north i'm my true north to set it
against anybody else is assuming that
they think like you do like you act like
you and nobody does you're unique you
are your own human you have to follow
your own path i love that example man
because
i noticed that ever since i was little i
would always like musicians that just
weren't cool to my friends and i play a
song for them and be like check this out
isn't that and they'd be like it's all
right
and i discovered pretty early on that
all the people i wanted to be like were
idiots to my friends
which means if i succeed at becoming the
guy i want to be i'm probably going to
be an idiot
that's right i am learning so much from
both of you especially that i've been
masturbating wrong this whole time
[Laughter]
incredible we're checking with the
patreon live stream here in a little bit
every tuesday at 10 a.m we do a patreon
live stream we answer your questions by
the way jacob thank you for your
question if you have a lightning round
question for us you can send us a text
937-202-4654
tk we gotta get you in on this um
those texts literally go to ryan's and
my phones
and we respond to a lot of people when
you you've been one of our live shows
before we asked people how many of you
have texted with us in half the crowd
and we just respond to people whenever
we can so you can send us whatever you
want your questions your eggplant emojis
whatever you want to send us
we'll 937-202-4654 your question on the
show or just send you a text message
alabama before we get to our other
segments and our patreon live stream
what else you got for us here's a
minimalist insight from one of our
listeners
hi ryan and josh this is amanda from
melbourne about a year ago after
listening to a few of your podcasts i
decided to start decluttering my house
i struggled getting started though as
the whole task felt too overwhelming
luckily for me i had a good friend who
was in the same situation and we agreed
to join forces
for the last 12 months my friend sam and
i spent every friday together
alternating between her house and mine
helping each other work our way through
every cupboard shelf and storage area
some weeks have been really emotionally
stressful
some have seen us covered from head to
toe in dust
but we have donated and thrown away
hundreds of kilograms of no longer
needed items and have had a lot of fun
along the way all right y'all big thanks
to matt nathanson for joining us today
check out his new album it's called
boston accent
and find him on tour matt nathanson.com
he's going to be all over the u.s in the
coming months you can also check out his
patreon we'll put a link to that in the
show notes before we get to our added
value segment tk real quick right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life of the minimalists we're
doing a monthly event we're sort of
going on the road as well but on the
road to la
you can come see us well sort of the
event filled up in about an hour but you
can get on the wait list right now it's
sunday symposium over at
sundaysymposium.com you can find all the
details what are we doing on these
sunday symposiums tk we're going to step
through and beyond the screen and we're
going to connect with each other as
human beings
we're going to be in the same place
we're going to talk together we're going
to laugh together maybe we even cry
together hopefully we won't die together
but we can hug each other uh handshake
and all those different things you know
a lot of us have been uh on lockdown
locked up locked in uh not locked up
uh some of us have well some some of us
have man some of us have uh
metaphorically and and physically and um
i i think now more than ever it's so
important for us to be able to get out
and have real contact with real human
beings and not just
make our inferences about each other
based on what somebody else is mediating
to us we're talking about community
we're talking about connection that's
right and there is this type of death
it's a death of what was we're trying to
move forward let go of that past the
death of the past let's let go together
you can join us you can get on the wait
list right now because as soon as more
tickets open up
you know ryan and uh actually uh the
whole team and i jordan and sean and
alabama danny unknown we went out to the
venue it's called dynasty typewriter
real close to downtown los angeles it's
200 seats
stunning perfect venue and they are
really simpatico with us too they share
our values and we got to meet the owner
out there spend some time with them
learn the tech learn the venue we're
gonna form a relationship with them as
well create this community space and you
can join us sunday symposium dot com get
on the wait list right now because as
soon as tickets open up by the way
they're gonna be free tickets or you can
donate money to help us pay for the
venue if you can't afford a ticket
though there'll be some free ones there
sunday symposium dot com also one other
thing that's going on in the life of the
minimalists you know i teach a writing
class tk it's called how to write better
but every wednesday if you don't want to
take a full writing class that's okay
all right there's not even one available
yet there's going to be maybe one more
this year i only teach it two or three
times a year but every wednesday
professor sean and i we send out a
little
write better wednesday text message
and if you're on our text all you have
to do is text the word hemingway
hemingway
to 937-202-4654
and if you text the word hemingway
that'll put you on our write better
wednesday list and i will send you a
writing tip every wednesday to help you
improve your writing that day something
you can implement into your writing
right now it's the sequel to my course
how to write good
you know originally i was going to call
it how to write gutter
but i don't know uh i think that would
just went over people said you can find
details how to write better.org if you
want to follow the youtube channel or
download the free ebook over there as
well it's called 15 ways to write better
for our added value this week since
we're celebrating matt nathan's brand
new album boston accent here's my
favorite song from that album it's
called
soundtrack
by the way tk we got a bunch more
surprise questions on the private
podcast this week like why did the
minimalists walk out of the emmys
how can you apply minimalism to
children's education
can you be an extreme minimalist and
still have a storage unit
plus seven different simple living
segments and a million more questions
and if you want to hear all that visit
the minimalists.com
private or click the link in the
description to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly maximal
episode plays in your favorite podcast
app you also gain immediate access to
all of our archives recordings of live
events weekly home tours and our private
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers like you
if you have a question or comment for
our podcast give us a call 406
219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com you can
follow the minimalist on tik-tok
instagram facebook and twitter at the
minimalists to get our podcast show
notes delivered directly to your inbox
just head on over and sign up for our
email list over at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus tk coleman alabama podcast
sean jordan no more professor sean
social jest danny unknown
post-production peter emma the immigrant
and the rest of our team
i'm joshua fields milburn if you leave
here today with just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all
peace
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it